The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT open courseware
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: So I'm
just putting In-Q-Tel out
there as probably the
most extreme example
of governmental willingness
to intervene in territories
we thought the government
really wouldn't do.
Right?
And, again, it's an example of
this national security state
doctrine that David
Hart told us about.
Whatever is needed for national
security, we're going to do,
however interventionist
it might be.
And this is a good example.
So Ruth David, a very
talented former CIA Director
for Science and
Technology, comes up
with the idea of creating this
entity to sponsor IT research.
Because the CIA realized
it was falling behind.
It wasn't part of
the IT revolution.
It didn't understand,
wasn't a participant,
and yet it was going to
be absolutely critical.
And, of course,
virtually no day passes
without reading
in the newspapers
about some latest cyber
security set of issues.
So In-Q-Tel is set up as a
government venture capital
firm, a completely unique model.
And it's aimed at early
stage technology development.
So the CIA is not new to
technology development.
I mean, in aerospace, the
U2 and SR-71 blackbird
are two of the most famous and
spectacular aircraft ever put
together.
They were put together
by Lockheed skunk works.
But In-Q-Tel really is
a very different model.
So Norm Augustine, who
had been CEO of Lockheed--
and is the winner of the
president's National Medal
of Technology, by the way,
so a great technologist
in his own right--
he helps in the
founding of this.
And they pick a CEO right
out of Silicon Valley.
And they've got a board
with ties to IT innovators,
as well as economic
researchers, and VC firms,
and tech companies.
So In-Q-Tel is allowed to
enter into joint ventures, i.e.
In effect, it can
co-own the companies
that it's nurturing to
bring along IT technologies
that the CIA is going
to be interested in.
It can use sole source grants.
It can set up open competitions.
It can award sole source
development contracts.
It's got a set of powers
here that are really quite
interventionist in the model.
And the CIA itself doesn't
review its business deals.
It's because it's
a bit offshore.
So it collaborates with the
CIA, but it's independent of it.
It has this set of
characteristics.
And we're going to talk
more about these kinds
of characteristics when
we do the great groups
class, the seventh class.
But agile, problem-driven,
solutions-focused,
team-oriented, technology aware,
output measured, innovative.
These are all kind
of characteristics
that In-Q-Tel likes to
say that it's capable of.
And these are some of
the technology areas
that In-Q-Tel, in its
earlier stages, worked on.
So a whole suite of IT-related
and software-related tech
capabilities.
So that's the model,
and it's different.
So, Chris, do you want to
bring us through it quickly.
CHRIS: So this is a
pretty unique situation.
Basically, it's kind
of posed as a win-win.
Like the CIA gets new
tech that they are kind of
behind in producing.
And then, these tech
companies, or In-Q-Tel,
has the opportunity
to get exposure
to potential big next problems
that they could develop
commercial products for.
So one question
that was posed was,
are there other such
private enterprises
funded by the government?
And if not, what is
preventing these partnerships
from happening.
I think Bill mentioned that
the Supreme unique case
so, probably, I
don't think there's
any other such partnerships.
But why is that, maybe?
AUDIENCE: They're
still around, are they?
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Oh yeah.
AUDIENCE: They
re-branded as IQT.
AUDIENCE: Ah, thank you.
I do remember there was one,
maybe it was similar to DARPA,
I remember in DARPA, at
least in the next reading,
there was something
that was similar.
Oh, that's right.
So I remember that one of
the points they mentioned
in this reading,
there was some sort
of licensing that
corporations needed
to work with the government.
Do you remember what it was?
Like, FRC licensing.
AUDIENCE: I think we were
just talking about that.
Like, level of strictness
of the contracts.
And how In-Q-Tel
works to restructure
how that contract works so that
they could encourage smaller
companies that
didn't want to deal
with overwhelming bureaucracy
to join the party.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Thanks.
[INAUDIBLE]
Good.
AUDIENCE: I was going to
say, I think agencies similar
to In-Q-Tel might
be a hard sell,
because if you think about--
they probably have a
pretty large employee base,
and they're privy
to information leak.
Also, it's going--
kind of directly
flying in the face of our
aversion to industrial policy.
So we are picking
winners, in this case.
So those two things I think
make it really difficult
to have other agencies
like this ourselves.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Right,
because really, in effect,
In-Q-Tel is a
venture capital firm.
It's not doing its own research.
It's a venture
capitalist, and it's
taking positions in
companies and helping
drive those companies
towards technology work
that's going to be relevant to
concerns that the CIA has got.
Sorry, Chris.
Go ahead.
CHLOE: Oh, no, I--
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Oh, Chloe.
CHLOE: I think it's interesting
to think about why this would
or wouldn't work
for other agencies,
because personally,
I'm surprised
that it has been such a
successful model for the CIA,
of all government agencies,
on several levels.
The article says
that they didn't
deal with any classified
work or contracts,
but I don't understand
how such a firm could
exist in partnership with an
agency that does any classified
work.
I don't see how--
I'm surprised that
that happened.
I am surprised, also, a
bit that that was able to--
yeah.
Start with that.
AUDIENCE: Which part are
you surprised by-- the fact
that they work so much
on non-classified stuff?
CHLOE: No, no.
They didn't.
In-Q-Tel, at least--
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
Yeah, they didn't
work on classified stuff.
CHLOE: So I'm surprised that--
I think, of all
agencies that I think
this model could work for,
I'm surprised that it works--
AUDIENCE: For someone who--
CHLOE: --the CIA.
AUDIENCE: --who
compartmentalizes
their information.
CHLOE: Yeah,
compartmentalizes information.
They were probably-- they
mentioned also, oh, there
will definitely
be people who will
raise questions
about ethics concerns
and the government meddling
in funding technologies
that they might simply
be interested in.
And feel like the CIA is
just the worst possible--
AUDIENCE: Customer?
CHLOE: Yeah.
It's really surprising to me.
AUDIENCE: I think--
yeah, it's really cool
that it works, and also kind of
shows that private enterprise
work with government.
Private enterprise has a strong
incentive to move quickly,
but I also think it's a
case study in terms of,
it was an IT revolution.
Their business is information
like information in general.
And if anybody's kind of better
than us, then we're screwed.
So they're like, we
really need to win.
We really need to win.
So I think there's
a strong stress
to actually make it work.
So there's probably
a lot of issues.
And I'll look from a management
perspective, a lot of times,
you don't say about
the bad things
when they write
stories about it.
So their-- I feel like, yeah, it
was really stressful probably,
the people from the--
because it's going to be
an old wing who's like,
yo, we don't want to do this.
And there was a
new wing who were
like, no, we need to do this.
So I think it might have been
a pretty stressful thing.
I can see how it
works, but I can also
see how they made it work.
CHLOE: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: That's my point.
AUDIENCE: Which
means that if it's
such a difficult situation,
and if they were still
able to make it work just out
of necessity, then [INAUDIBLE]
probably any other
government agency
could do something similar.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: So in order
that we get through everything,
I'm going to push this
ahead on this one.
But first, just a closing
thought, Chris, on this one?
CHRIS: I think the
central idea here,
that you can maybe
outsource what
you may be a little bit behind
in or aren't so good at,
is really interesting, so
that the CIA can effectively
focus on its core business,
which is gathering
and maintaining intel.
And this goes back to
our previous discussion
about the government
choosing winners and losers,
and it's really interesting
that this case has emerged
as the real case that they've
chosen a clear winner here,
and they're actually
forging a pretty strong
public-private partnership
that seems to work.
So yeah, this is a pretty
interesting article.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: And I wanted
to have Sarah Jane Maxted--
that is, our distinguished
visitor in our class today--
just introduce herself briefly.
And maybe, Sarah Jane, you
can tell the team some things
you're working on.
SARAH JANE MAXTED: Sure.
I'm Sarah Jane Maxted, also SJ.
[INAUDIBLE] refer to me.
I might pop in a few
other times as well.
I work at MIT.
I run a program called the
Regional Entrepreneurship
Acceleration Program.
We work with global
regions all over the world
to accelerate their
innovation ecosystem.
So my background--
I'm not that old,
but my specialization is
in innovation ecosystems.
Specifically, my background's
most directly related
to the energy space.
So I worked in the US
Department of Energy,
and I worked for a
US senator, and I
worked in the private sector
as well, all in relation
to energy and
innovation ecosystems.
So how do you cultivate--
how do you deal with
this valley of death?
And so it was so
interesting being
in the beginning of
this conversation,
talking about not
using market terms.
And when I worked in
the federal government,
we were not allowed to
say commercialization.
It was the death word.
It was ridiculous.
I was like, why
can't we just use it?
To your point,
that helps clarify.
So it was very frustrating.
It's been really great to hear.
AUDIENCE: What words did
you use as an alternative?
SARAH JANE MAXTED:
Tech to market.
[LAUGHTER]
We also weren't allowed
to say marketing.
Marketing was absolutely not OK.
AUDIENCE: What
about tech transfer?
SARAH JANE MAXTED: Yeah.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
SARAH JANE MAXTED: That was OK.
Congressmen didn't love it.
But it's really fascinating
to hear each of you guys.
You guys are very well-versed.
I'm quite impressed.
But yeah, any questions
on that front.
And what I'm doing
here at MIT, I also
work with the
Innovation Initiative.
I think somebody
mentioned earlier
some of the educational
things related to innovation
entrepreneurship and
business, and being
able to have
multiple skill sets.
And I am interested
at some point
to hear what you guys think
about the minor in innovation
and entrepreneurship, which
was launched last year.
Maybe some of you
are part of it.
But anyways, that's
what I [INAUDIBLE]..
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Thank you.
SARAH JANE MAXTED:
You're welcome.
Thank you for having me.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: All right.
Now we're going to crash through
the last couple of readings.
This is a piece I did in 2014.
And essentially,
I began to realize
that there were different
periods at which point
we began to reorient in
the US our understanding
and the organization of
our innovation system
towards, heaven forbid,
commercialization.
And I roughly delineated
five periods--
the immediate postwar,
the Sputnik period,
the 1980s competitiveness
period, and then more recently,
these new potential
innovation waves
that are coming in--
energy for sure,
I think, but also potentially
advanced manufacturing.
And the US essentially had
to rethink the Vannevar Bush
disconnected model that it
brought into place in the early
postwar, and create a
more connected model.
And each one of
these stages presents
movement towards more
connected kinds of systems.
So the postwar period
you're familiar with.
That's Vannevar Bush himself.
And he creates a highly
connected model during the war,
as we've discussed,
and then disconnects it
as we've gone through
and talked about--
particularly from
the Stokes reading--
at the close of World War II.
So this is where,
as we said before,
our great, strong, and
certainly very important
basic research
organizations come from.
And as we've talked before, we
get a lot out of that model.
But Sputnik is an attempt--
led by the Defense Department,
but embracing other pieces
like NASA and NSF--
where the Defense
Department pushes
on that disconnected model.
The Defense Department can't
take a disconnected model.
It just won't work.
It's got to have
fairly rapid movement
towards actual
technology development.
And to an extent a
system is disconnected,
it's not going to
serve DoD well.
So DoD, in the course of the
Cold War-- and certainly,
this is rampant by 1957--
is rebuilding its much
more connected, World War
II-like system, with deep ties
between industry, university
research systems and efforts,
and the defense lab system.
So DoD plays a pervasive role
at every stage of the pipeline,
as we've talked
about previously.
So if that's the
innovation pipeline,
our classic basic
research agencies
are playing, at this
stage, research and maybe
invention of
early-stage prototypes,
maybe into early-stage
development, but that's it.
Whereas the Defense Department,
as we've talked about,
will perform the
research, the development,
fund the prototype,
fund the demonstration,
fund the test bed, and move
into actual production,
often creating initial
markets for new technologies.
That's the IT story that
we've begun to tell.
We'll tell a little more when
we talk more about DARPA.
So DoD has got a much more
connected system, because
of its potential--
and it doesn't always
play a role at every
one of these stages,
but it potentially plays
a role at all of them.
So it's a very different
organizational model,
as we've been
talking about today.
DARPA comes right out of
the Sputnik challenge.
It's set up in '58.
Sputnik is '57.
President Eisenhower had
been completely frustrated
that the three
separate service space
programs were not
talking to each other
and not sharing ideas.
Each of the services was
pursuing a rival effort
to capture what was then
known as the higher ground,
and put that higher
ground project
into its own
procurement program.
So the Army and the
Air Force and Navy all
had their own separate
missile programs.
Eisenhower wakes up,
stuck with Sputnik,
appropriately
blames the services
for not having
undertaken collaboration.
Eisenhower decides, I'm
taking space away from you.
We're going to create
this DARPA thing,
and it's going to report to
the Secretary of Defense,
and we're going to run
it as a unified program.
That only lasts a few months,
because there's a big movement
to have a civilian agency led
in space, not a military agency.
So then NACA-- which was the
Aeronautical Research Agency
that, actually, Vannevar
Bush led in the 1930s,
which is where he learns
his innovation organization
lessons--
that becomes NASA, and
becomes aeronautics and space,
and is essentially created
around the Apollo mission.
Max?
MAX: Quick question
regarding the previous slide.
You mentioned that the
DoD is basically involved
in all of these steps,
whereas places like the DoE
are not involved.
Why isn't the DoE involved?
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: The
Department of Energy
doesn't have a--
Sarah Jane can
tell us about this,
but it doesn't have
a procurement budget,
so it doesn't buy stuff.
So DoD buys its stuff.
It will buy the technology
advances that it's supporting.
It will buy aircraft.
It will buy IT systems.
It will create
the initial market
for the integrated circuit
for its own computer needs.
The Department of Energy doesn't
have a procurement budget,
therefore it's
limited in its ability
to do this creation
of initial markets
and undertake support
of the production stage.
It's hard-- look, in the
end, the energy technology--
we're going to talk about it.
We'll do a whole case
study on energy, which I
hope will sort of satisfy you.
But in the end, we're
going to stand up
an energy technology revolution
in the private sector.
There's no pretending
that a government contract
model is going to
achieve that revolution.
It's gotta get stood up
in the private sector.
So I don't think it
solves our problem.
I think that we
have to recognize
the reality that 12% of
the economy is in energy.
It's going to be
a civilian sector.
Let's figure out how to
stand those technologies up
in that civilian sector, because
that's the lasting model.
I mean, it wouldn't hurt.
The DoE would buy certain stuff.
But Congress is just not
going to give it the power.
And Sarah Jane's comments
about the unwillingness
to talk about, God
forbid, commercialization,
is symptomatic--
much less initial
market creation.
So it's a challenge in
other organizations.
Third period is around
competitiveness.
So from 1973 to 1991--
and we talked about this
in the first class--
the US economy
significantly slowed.
And this is where the
Rust Belt comes from.
This is the first great job
disruption in manufacturing.
This is Japan's brilliant
quality production
model coming to bear against
an earlier model of US
mass production, and
quality production
proved the better model.
And US GDP growth historically
is around the 3% level.
It came down to the 2% level.
US productivity
growth, historically
around the 2% level, comes
down to the 1% level.
Lower productivity growth
means a lower GDP growth.
This is not a happy time.
This is a tough time
in the United States.
By the way, current growth rate
in the United States is 2%.
Productivity rate is 1%.
Comparable economic problem.
Economists now call
this secular stagnation.
We had that period for an
extended period of time.
and the US had
organized its economy
around frontier innovation, but
it missed an innovation wave.
And when you
organize your economy
around frontier innovation
and you miss a wave,
it's a problem.
So when Japan--
and, to some extent,
Germany as well-- leads this
manufacturing revolution,
a real innovation wave
around quality production,
the US misses the wave
and has to catch up.
So in this time
period, particularly
in the '80s It's trying
to rethink its model
and figure out how to
be more competitive,
with particularly the
economies in Japan and Germany.
And the models that it came
up with were the following.
So a lot of interesting
things happened
that are, in effect,
more connected.
And the government is
going to be pushing further
down the pipeline.
The Bayh Dole Act.
The government used to own
the intellectual property
rights to federal research.
The government is not
a company, so it just
went and sat on the shelf.
Bayh Dole Act gives
intellectual property ownership
to the universities that
are conducting the research,
and they in turn share it
with their researchers.
It makes the university
an economic actor.
So universities have done
education and research
for a long time.
Suddenly they've got
an economic stake
in the outcomes
of their research.
So increasingly, we are
drawing universities
in to the economic
system and having
them play an economic role.
Whole new development.
And the Bayh Dole Act is not
the only thing going on here,
but it's one significant
part of the story.
We create the Manufacturing
Extension Program
to bring the latest
manufacturing
technologies and processes
to small manufacturers.
So the majority of
US production is
done by small firms and
mid-sized firms that
have less than 500 employees.
They don't do any R&D. They
have a lot of trouble--
as we talked about in the
manufacturing classes--
keeping up with
technology advances.
So the MEP program is an attempt
to bring the latest technology
advances and process advances
to small manufacturers.
And here, there is
an explicit attempt
to understand what Japan
is undertaking in quality
manufacturing and
translate that model back
to small and mid-sized
manufacturers.
We create the advanced
technology program NIST.
That's now over, on
precisely the reasons
we've been talking about.
That was viewed as
too interventionist.
The Commerce Department was
supporting company research
at the applied level, and it was
viewed as too interventionist.
Eventually, Congress
shuts it down.
The Small Business Innovation
and Research Program.
As we've talked before, when
you all set up your startups,
this is the first place
you're going to go for money.
This is where you go,
and you can get up
to about a million dollars
in two different phases
to really do startup efforts.
And the number of startups
that have used SBIR money--
they all use it.
It's very critical.
That program comes out
of this general era.
Sematech at DoD, that we've
talked about briefly earlier
today, is another program--
also quite interventionist--
where essentially,
the government attempts an
advanced manufacturing project
in the semiconductor sector.
So these are all
program elements
that began developing
in this period.
Interestingly, we don't
have to follow through,
because Japan misses the
IT revolution that really
begins to hit at about 1990.
The US leads it.
We did very well very quickly
starting in that 1990s time
period--
one of the most successful
economic periods
in US 20th century, 21st
century economic history.
So we forgot the
problems we had.
And of course, those
manufacturing problems
are now right back on us,
because we didn't fully
follow through.
Period 4 is the problem
of energy innovation.
We're going to do a
whole class on this.
I'm not going to
spend much time on it.
But energy is driving
the organizational model,
and an organization
like ARPA-E--
a DARPA within DoE--
explicitly has what Sarah
Jane reminded us of--
a tech to market outlook that
really very much considers
the possibilities of
commercialization before it
selects the R&D projects
it's going to fund.
Is there a pathway
to commercialization?
There's a conscious
attempt there.
So this is not a
curiosity-driven, Vannevar Bush
basic research agency.
ERE explicitly works with
industry for the great bulk
of its research portfolio.
Advanced manufacturing.
We've talked about
this one as well.
This may be an evolving
innovation movement.
We'll see what the
current administration
wants to do with it.
It's not clear yet.
So those are five periods.
I'll just recap.
Period 1, the postwar.
We move from a wartime
connected system
to a disconnected system.
And then slowly over
time we've been,
creating more and more
connections in our system.
So Sputnik creates
DARPA, and we'll
talk a good bit about DARPA.
I'm just laying the groundwork
here on several topics,
including this one.
But a reconnection of the whole
Defense innovation system.
Period 3, around
competitiveness.
We do a series of experiments--
which, with one exception,
all of which remain in place
and have been pretty
successful over time--
to attempt better
connections between industry
and the commercialization
efforts and university
research.
And then the energy challenge
and advanced manufacturing
challenge push us further
down that pipeline.
The advanced
manufacturing institutes
and manufacturing
that we talked about,
those bring together
collaborations
of private sector firms,
government, and university
researchers for a collaborative
effort around developing
new advanced technologies.
It's not early-stage technology.
It's very applied.
It's quite late-stage.
A lot of development.
So these are much-- this is the
government supporting an effort
to move much further
down the pipeline
towards commercialization
of these new technologies.
Who's got this one?
RASHEED: Me.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Good.
RASHEED: So bringing
together these five periods,
I thought these were pretty--
these held up pretty well
with all the readings
that we've done so far.
In particular, I think the
postwar and the Sputnik one
we've kind of gone
over in spades.
But a little bit newer, I think,
is the period 3 through 5.
But particularly, if we focus
on '80s competitiveness,
we see that that's spurred
on a little bit towards--
with the advent of Sematech
and semiconductors,
and missing its innovation
wave with Japan.
And is there sort of this--
so what we want to
find out here is,
is there an idea
that globalization
brings about new forms?
So now that we have this
'80s competitiveness,
these periods get a lot shorter.
So the '80s, and the
period 4 is in the 2000s,
and now we're in
advanced manufacturing.
So is there this opportunity
for globalization
to make these innovation
waves maybe shorter,
or add more and make them more
compact so more people have
this opportunity?
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
Rasheed, I think
that's an important
point, because actually,
each one of these
stages are driven
by external developments landing
on the US economic situation
and forcing change.
So they're just not
materializing from within.
These are all
external developments
that force a US response.
So you make an important point.
RASHEED: But is this something
that you guys also saw, maybe,
with the idea that
globalization will
bring more innovation
to the forefront--
maybe not just in the US, but
elsewhere as well, and make
other people respond in
the way that we have?
MAX: At least
intuitively it does,
because if you have more
people that are talking,
more people that are exchanging
ideas through globalization,
then by extension,
you would think
that would mean that more
ideas can get produced
and people have access
to more resources, which
means that whatever
ideas that come up with,
they can implement better.
So at least intuitively.
AUDIENCE: I would challenge
the resource point, though,
because that would
trigger [INAUDIBLE]..
AUDIENCE: No, I was going to
talk about everyone talking,
if that's a good thing, because
usually, the best decisions are
made when everybody's
following along the same path,
and it's also not
mainly just one person
thinking for themselves.
If you think about Wall
Street and speculation--
because you get an echo chamber.
And this was shown by
the whole Facebook case
after the election,
where everyone
was saying the same things.
So it's usually--
a lot of evasion
happens when an
individual thinks
of a different perspective
and then echoes back
to the community.
So if you can have individual
figures, it's really good.
But usually what happens
is, because of dogma or just
the way groups work, there's
very few innovative ideas,
and it's more of
an echo chamber.
AUDIENCE: Well, that's true,
but that's been true always.
So my thought is that having
a greater access to more
communities that have
these different ideas,
then you have more
of those Zuckerbergs
who are thinking of
something different.
AUDIENCE: Perhaps.
AUDIENCE: I would
say, getting back
to Rasheed's original
question or point,
I think that we
probably are seeing
a contraction of
technology waves,
or these periods, probably
due to just the speed at which
information can be transferred.
That might explain it.
RASHEED: Also, I'll
argue that financing
and getting a reputation
for things, that's easier
now, because back in
the day during Edison
or during Ford's
day, getting money
was a huge problem
for an entrepreneur.
Nowadays, it's very
easy to get money.
And also, you get
to keep your equity,
because back in the day,
too, you would create--
you could create one of
the best technologies,
and you would give up 1/3 your
company or the full company,
and then they'd kick you out.
So you came up with
this innovation.
You understand technology,
how to bring it to market.
And now, because this person
wants to make more money,
they kick you out.
So that's really a
good opportunity,
because now it's really
the technologist who
has more power.
So that's why these
cycles are [INAUDIBLE]..
AUDIENCE: But see,
that's exactly where--
the point at which I
would challenge Max,
because just because we have
a globalized spread of ideas
doesn't mean that we have a
globalized spread of resources.
And often our innovation,
especially the United States,
is built on imperialism.
Dependency theory, borrowing
from [INAUDIBLE] economics,
is one of the reasons why the
United States and why colonial
governments were able to
make such incredible gains.
In particular, we saw this with
the Dutch East India Company.
Their exploitation
of Southeast Asia
was exactly what enabled them
then to promote, I guess,
a Marxist society
in the Netherlands,
and then enabled the spread of
colonization in the New World.
And so what we're seeing now,
especially with the innovate
here, produce there
paradigm is, I think--
and the sort of detriments that
we talked about maybe three
classes ago, about the ways
in which countries are now
understanding how to
innovate there as well--
is that we may be
sharing all of our ideas,
but there's not going to be a
capture of value economically
or in terms of the practical
gain of technological advances,
because those resources
are not local.
We're going to have to purchase
them from other countries.
And if the United States doesn't
have access to those resources
and production
and manufacturing,
then we're going to miss out on
the benefits of having created
those ideas domestically.
And that's what I think
is so treacherous about
the international
relations landscape
that the Trump administration
is creating for us,
and why it's really
important for us
to be wary of our reputation
on the international plane,
because we don't have all
of the resources necessary
in order to produce, and if we
destroy our reputation abroad,
people won't want
to work with us.
And if they now have
the innovation capacity
as well, then what is the
future for American innovation?
Imperialism hegemony does not
exist for Americans anymore.
AUDIENCE: But I would argue two
points on what you just said.
One is, the interesting
thing about Trump
is, he became such a polarizing
figure that abroad, people
know we don't like him.
So it's like, that's just him.
That's not the US.
And then two, I
think you're thinking
about-- your framework
is based on the past,
in terms of what's happened.
And I think in the past,
it's been very much--
we're a scarcity society.
So there's a scarce
amount of resources,
so we need to take
from somebody else.
So there's been--
there's a philosopher who
talked about how we
have so many enemies,
and the US creates so
many enemies because we
used to take, take, take.
But I think what will change
in the next 100 years,
200 years is that
we will get closer
to like a post-scarcity society
so that we have more resources.
Say people discover a better
form of energy, so we have--
assume infinite energy,
even though that's ideal.
Assume we have water, because
we've figured out desalination,
so we can get enough food.
Assume that now we
have automation,
so people don't have to
work with their hands
and more people can think.
And then assume we're
expanding, and we go into space.
So now we're also-- it's
like the American period
of growth, where people
are expanding other places.
So the game before was to
take and take and take.
And if the game becomes
more to, how do you give?
What becomes valuable
once you already--
to have money
wouldn't be valuable.
It would be respect.
It'd be, this person
got a Nobel Prize.
This person did a
social initiative.
That's just an evolution
of what you just said.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: So you
guys are really leading us out
of here.
[LAUGHTER]
Go off into utopia land.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, really.
RASHEED: [INAUDIBLE] That
was four individual points.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AUDIENCE: But the thing is--
AUDIENCE: Bring it back.
AUDIENCE: --from a
startup perspective,
you don't think linearly.
You think exponentially.
So we're talking about
these contractions.
That could be a
reality in terms of--
if you think about how
the past used to be,
that's not the game
we're playing anymore.
RASHEED: Yeah.
I don't think that's the
game we're playing anymore.
You could probably
look at these,
and that's pretty already--
you're already
looking exponential.
AUDIENCE: It could be
bioengineering, energy,
and physics all at once.
RASHEED: Yeah, which I
think offers the opportunity
to be pretty cool.
And I think ARPA-E--
we can focus on them a
little bit now, on period 4--
is looking at these
interdeparmental collaborative
mechanisms to spur these
short-term, three-to-five-year,
very industry-focused
targeted growth periods.
And so is that an idea that
we want to kind of take back,
is can we look at-- now that
we're so interconnected in all
of this globalization,
[INAUDIBLE] try to create is,
can we focus all of these
things in these targeted areas
with any degree of success?
Or are we just playing the
game, gambling [INAUDIBLE]??
MAX: So you're saying
to focus the defense--
for example, the Department
of Energy, you would say,
focus it only on
one form of energy.
Is that what you're asking?
RASHEED: Let me take this back.
SARAH JANE MAXTED: Hear
about the mechanism.
RASHEED: Yeah.
So as a mechanism--
does the mechanism work?
But the mechanism
is basically, you
have this idea for
advanced materials,
and you take a couple
of industry partners--
the Department of
Energy, for example,
and maybe even an
international partner-- and you
make them all work together on
an advanced materials project
for three to five years.
Do you think all of these
people can get together and work
effectively in the
short time span
to produce any
degree of success?
MAX: Well, obviously, I have
a bit of a pension for fusion,
so my first thought's
going to be here--
the International Thermonuclear
Experimental Reactor--
partially because science
and engineering for plasma
is just really
hard, and partially
because I feel that,
at least in my opinion,
it hasn't been managed
as effectively as it
could have been.
It was supposed to
be the best example
that I can think of
international collaboration
trying to solve a
very big problem.
And it's more than
double its first budget,
and it's, what, 10, 20
years behind schedule?
Of course, that's not to say
that the approach itself--
the fact that you're using
international resources--
that's not to say that
that is inherently flawed.
But I can't really think
of any counterexamples.
AUDIENCE: The way we think about
it as a businessperson is--
this a pretty common problem--
is, you stress people.
I gave the case example
before of Silicon Valley,
and how there's not
minorities and there
weren't that many women.
So sometimes what you do is,
you actually make the problem
be very apparent.
And so the CEO of
a company knows,
there's a problem in my company.
They won't announce it,
but they'll leak a paper.
And somebody will be like,
oh, there's a real problem.
And then everyone's like,
oh, we need to solve this.
Oh my god, there's
all this press.
And you use the tools
at your disposal.
And so, yeah, you can--
you have to stress them
just the right way,
because people would
stay by themselves
in their own little bubble.
But if you stress them
so it's like, oh no,
we need to do this,
we need this now,
that's how I think about it.
MAX: Actually-- oh, sorry.
SARAH JANE MAXTED: No, no.
I was just going to say,
I think the question that
gets beyond the mechanism
itself of the ARPA-E
is, how do you monitor
or evaluate success?
So I think-- to your point, some
technologies take a lot longer.
So is three to four or five
years a good time horizon?
And if we keep it at
that, that's fine,
but how do we bundle in
all these different energy
technologies?
For instance, for some, maybe
more building technologies
are going to be a lot quicker,
and then some, like fusion,
are going to take much longer.
And how do you identify
the right technologies
or applied research to
do in that capacity,
and how do you
evaluate the success?
And that's the tech to
market question as well--
what are those points of
evaluation?-- which is,
I think, [INAUDIBLE].
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
Sarah, you're driving us,
I think, to some
additional perceptions
here given your basic
question, Rasheed.
What are the innovation
organization models
that we're going to
use if we're trying
to take on these bigger tasks?
In other words, it was
straightforward enough
to do a curiosity-driven
research project and fund one
PI.
But if we're moving the
model to move much further
down the pipeline, which is
what all these stages represent,
what are the organizational
mainstay models
we're going to use here?
And then you come to a
model like the manufacturing
institutes, which
can typically have
more than 100 companies;
four or five major research
universities; a comparable
number of community colleges,
if not more; and, potentially,
one or more federal agencies
and five or six states and
state economic development
organizations.
As some of the
Defense Department
described this to me, standing
up a manufacturing institute
is like standing up a country,
compared to funding a single PI
researcher.
So these call for--
and I think is what
Rasheed is driving us to
and Sarah is driving us to--
they call for a much more
complex organizational model,
because the tasks have
gotten considerably larger,
and the number of actors
that need to be involved
is getting considerably larger.
So these are all
lessons learned that I
think we're going
to have to pull out
of the experiments were running
now on energy and potentially
advanced manufacturing,
and really consider
the models we're using.
Rasheed, do you want
to give us a closing
thought about this reading?
RASHEED: Yeah.
I thought this reading
was pretty comprehensive,
and it seemed very
Bill, I would say,
because it did a good
job of starting us
from the beginning at
this postwar system
and walking us all
the way through now
to advanced manufacturing
and the [INAUDIBLE] problems
that we have today.
So it was pretty--
I felt like I was in class,
reading through and--
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: I felt
like, I've done this.
RASHEED: Yeah, yeah.
And then you get to the new
stuff at the end, and you're--
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
Rasheed, I had
to write this because I needed
it in class, because there
wasn't anything else that
covered this entire panoply.
So that's really, frankly,
the reason why I wrote it.
All right.
We're now going to jump
to another Bill reading,
and now we're going
to take a deep dive
into this whole concept
of legacy sectors.
And this will be foundational as
we do some of the case studies,
like in energy,
like in health care.
AUDIENCE: If I
could just ask you,
at the very end of this last
[INAUDIBLE] just talking about,
you have--
I guess your driving
conclusion is
that the new model innovation
organizations discussed here
deserve ongoing scrutiny
and pragmatic evaluation
of their performance
to refine these models.
Obviously, you published
this three years ago,
and were probably thinking
of this five years ago.
So I was curious if you could
talk a little bit about how
you've maybe developed
that already,
or if you've been thinking about
what a model might look like.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
Well, I learned a lot
in working on the advanced
manufacturing initiative--
the Advanced
Manufacturing Partnership
that the President set
up, and the Production
in the Innovation
Economy project at MIT,
because it really
forced a lot of thinking
about what the organizational
model was going to be.
And in turn, I've learned
a tremendous amount
about looking at what
the Department of Energy
has been doing.
So we'll dive into this
in the energy case study,
but essentially,
DoE, at the front end
of the innovation,
the R&D stage,
has created a whole
set of new models.
It is a very different agency
than it was 10 years ago.
And it's created a
host of new pieces
on the innovation
front that enable
it to do a lot more things.
So yes, they still have a
Vannevar Bush basic research
agency--
the Office of
Science, a $5 billion
basic research
organization-- but they've
got all these other pieces
on the table now which
make the mix quite interesting.
So we'll have a chance,
actually, Steph,
to dive into what some of
those models look like.
We'll take a particular look at
ARPA-E, which is actually maybe
on the chopping
block at the moment.
So it may turn out to
be an historical lesson.
But a pretty interesting
organizational model.
But let me do
another driver here
that forces us to think about
innovation organization, which
is innovation in legacy sectors.
So the US is pretty good
at doing the next big thing
and standing up new technologies
in frontier territories.
In other words, in effect--
to use a metaphor--
we take our new technologies,
we put them into covered wagons,
we go across the mountain, and
we open up a new technology
territory.
We do frontier innovation,
and we're pretty good at this.
There was nothing really like
computing before computing.
So that would be a good
example of opening up
a whole new territory.
The US is not good at bringing
innovation into legacy sectors.
The new innovations often
have to parachute in,
and they get shot
at on the way down.
So the US tends to do
the next big thing,
but doesn't tend to go
back and fix the old.
That's why the-- driving from
Kennedy Airport into Manhattan
often is kind of a
third-world experience.
Sometimes you think you could
lose an axle on your cab
before you get into downtown.
We don't tend to maintain a
lot of our existing systems.
We push on to the
next big thing.
And that's not bad.
That's not a bad
American tendency.
But we do pay a
price for it if we're
going to have to bring
innovation into these legacy
sectors.
Just think of the
health care debate
we've been having
in recent months.
The United States does biotech.
It does not go back and fix the
health care delivery system.
That's a legacy sector.
That would be hard.
We'd rather open a new thing.
So this is a problem
in our society.
Look, every society
has got these problems.
It's hard for anybody to
innovate in the legacy sectors.
But it's particularly
tough here, I would argue.
And the problem is that a lot
of our big societal problems
are tied to these
legacy sectors.
We can't avoid the innovation
challenge in these sectors--
climate and energy,
food and water,
the problem we've got of quality
job creation, health care
delivery, improving education
to address inequality problems.
These are all profound
societal challenges,
and they all have to be
fixed within legacy sectors.
And to do this, we've got
to confront these sectors.
Frankly, I was--
Chuck Weiss and I, my co-author,
were amazed we wrote this book.
There's no literature on this.
There's no literature
in the innovation policy
field about innovating
in legacy sectors.
It's a problem that's just
hidden in plain sight.
So how would we do this?
Because we need to do it.
One example is the revolution in
military affairs in the defense
sector in the 1990s,
where we bring
a raft of new technologies to
bear even though the Defense
Department is one of the
most notorious legacy sectors
around.
How is it the DoD is
able to organize to bring
these technology advances in?
But we can start to see a
whole set of innovations
that are starting
to move in what
we can consider legacy sectors.
So advanced manufacturing.
Manufacturing is
definitely a legacy sector.
New energy technologies.
Intelligent cars.
Higher education for
sure is a legacy sector.
We're starting to
see online education.
Commercial space.
So there are possibilities here.
We're starting to see what some
of the possibilities might be.
So learning how to innovate
in these sectors is critical.
What are some of the
take-home lessons?
There are obstacles
to innovation
in the legacy sectors.
Innovation, by the way, is
not just the shiny new lights
and only the cutting edge.
There's a lot of
innovation that needs
to land in these
legacy sectors that
are not quite as glamorous.
Legacy sectors have a lot
in common, both in the US
and abroad.
So there are definitional
aspects of a legacy sector
that apply to manufacturing, but
also to health care delivery.
We can find commonalities here.
And legacy sectors in
countries here and abroad
have commonalities.
And the context of innovation
can be every bit as important
as the innovation system itself.
So this class is focused
on the innovation system,
but it's within
a larger context.
And I'll explain what
that means in a minute.
Entrenched legacy sectors
resist innovation.
For example, we often
provide incentives
to producers that don't
align with societal needs.
The legacy sectors are defended
by a technological, economic,
political, social, and maybe
even cultural paradigm.
So a legacy sector
is a castle, and it's
got a rich defense system.
That is, it defends
the technology advances
that it's encouraged.
It will defend the economic
models that it's pursued.
It will use the political
system to block change.
And it uses societal
and educational systems
to ensure that it
gets staffed up
and has a social outlook
that tends to protect it.
So these legacy sectors tend
to share this common paradigm.
They will resist
disruptive innovation,
and they will be more
accepting of innovations that
fit their own business models.
And we'll talk about
that in a second.
The features of
the legacy sector,
they get a little
definitional, and I
don't want to go into a
lot of details on these.
But you get the idea.
And these are
characteristics that--
a legacy sector will share
all of these characteristics,
but it will
typically share many.
In the characteristics
side, there
are often perverse
prices that don't
reflect externalities-- i.e.,
like the low cost of gasoline.
There will be an
established infrastructure--
gas stations.
Massive infrastructure
system that's got
to get rethought and overcome
if you're going to make change.
There are strong
public expectations
of low cost of energy
in the United States.
It's very hard to
overcome these.
There are often
regulatory requirements
that block entry
of new technology--
again, in the energy space.
Good luck in connecting your
out of state new solar system
with the transmission system
across a series of states.
You've going to have
to get the states'
regulatory systems lined up.
It's very tough.
There are career
pathways and curricula
at universities that tend to
support the existing system.
All of these, there's
typically very limited R&D
compared to revenue.
So in the energy sector,
for example, less than 1%
of annual revenues is spent
on research and development
in the energy private sector.
An astonishingly low number
for a major industry.
And there are powerful vested
interests behind these legacy
sectors that defend them.
On terms of-- I'm not
going to go into detail
about these kind of
market imperfections,
but often perverse
subsidies, network economies,
non-appropriability where the
developer of the technology
can't recapture its value.
There's often problems
of collective action.
So for example, it's tough to
introduce technology advance
into the building sector because
it's so totally decentralized.
There are not major actors.
There's just lots and lots
and lots of little actors.
So you can't get
collective action together
in a sector that's
organized like that.
There's a short time
horizon for financing,
and that limits the
ability to scale up
new technology advances.
So these are-- now,
in contrast, if you're
developing a technology that
is compatible with the legacy
sector's paradigm of
technology and business model
and so forth, then
you can do it.
You can do it in
relatively short order.
So fracking was adapted within,
really, a 15-year period.
The original technology advances
came out of the national labs
around things like
3D seismic imaging.
And they moved very
quickly because fracking
fit the existing fossil
fuel economy so nicely.
If you're doing solar,
good luck to you.
It's a much more complicated
adaptation process.
So if you're doing
disruptive technologies,
that's where the
problem really comes in.
So we have a series of models
of the dynamics of innovation,
and we've been
struggling to see these
in the course of
the classes so far.
But as you think about it,
there's really five ways
that our economy
undertakes innovation.
One, we've spent a lot of time
last class and this class--
the pipeline.
Again, the model--
dump basic research
in the end of the
pipeline, mysterious things
happen, great products emerge.
That's technology push.
Federal government
is, in effect,
pushing a new kind of
technology or scientific advance
into the pipeline,
and hopefully it
will emerge from the pipeline.
It's a technology push model,
a technology supply model.
That's the dominant model
underlying US innovation
policy.
But there's also
induced innovation.
Remember, Vernon
Ruttan came up with
this theoretical framework.
Industry does the majority
of innovation in our economy.
Industry will typically see
a market niche or a market
opportunity and will move
to fill that opportunity--
typically with incremental
advances, not radical advances.
So that is a demand pull.
Industry is identifying
a potential demand
that can pull the technology
into the marketplace.
That's typically
what industry does.
But then there's other models.
The extended pipeline, we've
just been talking about today.
That's what the Defense
Department does.
It operates at every
stage of the pipeline.
So in addition to the pipeline
model in the US system,
we have an extended pipeline
model in the US system.
A fourth model is
manufacturing-led innovation.
US doesn't do this one.
We didn't build this one.
Countries like Germany
and Japan do this model.
Korea, Taiwan do this model.
China now jumped on this model.
In other words, their
innovation system
is led by the creative
work, the new engineering,
the new science that can
lead to produce products.
It's that product
design stage that's
central in a manufacturing-led
innovation system.
US never built one of these.
So by creating these
manufacturing institutes,
that's an attempt in the US to
get this piece into our system.
Overall, entry
into legacy sectors
is such a complex
effort that you're not
going to do one of these
innovation organization models.
You're going to have to
do probably all of them.
When you think about a
sector as complex as energy,
you've probably got to
tackle all of these dynamics
to get the changes you need.
So that puts a premium on
innovation organization,
the way in which you organize
your innovation system.
That becomes critical
when you're trying
to tackle a legacy sector.
Just as we were having
that conversation, Steph,
that you pushed for,
what's the new ways
of organizing around innovation?
What are the new models?
If you're trying to innovate
in a legacy sector like energy
or manufacturing, you're
going to need new models,
and you're going to need to
think about the innovation
dynamics at each
one of these points.
Oh, I don't want to forget.
You need change agents,
because legacy sectors will not
change themselves.
You're going to
have to have people
prepared to push these legacy
sectors to adapt change.
And maybe it's
political leadership.
Maybe it's new
companies and startups
that are going to be
the change agents.
Maybe it's a new R&D agency.
Maybe it's a mix of
all of the above.
But you're going to
need change agents that
are prepared to move things
in these legacy sectors.
So those are the five models.
Some of this calls for
us to think about what
the governmental role is.
Do we need a more
activist governmental role
in this kind of context?
What's the process?
And this is
particularly important,
because this is going to be
important in your papers.
So the stuff we're talking
about here is going to be--
in terms of launching
new technologies,
this multi-step,
five-step process
is going to be
something that I'm
going to ask you to use as you
consider the topics you develop
in your papers.
Step one-- you can't
innovate without innovation.
So you're going to need stuff.
So you're going to have to
have a front-end innovation
system that's giving
you creative stuff
to innovate with.
Here's some ideas here.
Form critical
innovation institutions.
Build thinking communities
so that you can have a--
you got have a community
that's big enough
to really get a lot of ideas
on the table for innovation
to occur.
It's Romer.
It's the prospective
theory here.
You've got to have a
thinking community that's
at a big enough scale that they
can really work on creating
innovations in a legacy sector.
You need to link the
technologists to the operators.
They can't be in
isolation from each other
if you want to
implement this stuff.
And you can use that
island and bridge model,
and we'll talk more
about this next week
when we talk about
innovation by great groups.
But your innovators need to
be connected decision-makers
that can effectuate the changes
they're going to propose.
Some other steps,
and then I'll quit
and we can do some
Q&A. Step two is,
each technology is going to
have a different launch path.
The launch path for
batteries for grid storage
is probably going to be a
very different launch path
than batteries for transport.
Launching into
the utility sector
versus launching
into cars, those
are different launch pathways.
So you're going to have to think
about what the launch pathway
is for your technology
that you want
to have enter the marketplace.
And then you're going to
need to tie support packages
to those launch
pathways that fit,
that are relevant to the
particular launch pathways.
A fourth step is, look at the
innovation system and the gaps
in the innovation system.
What are the holes
in the system?
Where are things dying?
For sure it's the
valley of death,
but what are the other
gaps in that system?
Because again, the
valley of death
is only between research
and development.
You've got all kinds
of other stages
to get through, too, all
the way up into production.
What are the gaps in
that overall system?
So think about what the
gaps are, and then think
about institutional fixes--
public or private or both--
that fill those gaps.
So this is kind of a menu of
how to think about bringing
innovation into legacy sectors.
And if you all are going to
work in the energy field,
that's the king
of legacy sectors.
Right if you want to pursue
advanced manufacturing,
that is a big-time
legacy sector.
So we're going to have
to have a much more
sophisticated innovation
organization approach.
We're not going to solve these
problems by individual awards
to individual investigators.
That's not going to work.
It's not going to get us there.
We're going to have to have
a whole new delivery system
for the innovation system.
Let's see if there's anything
else I want to cover.
Change agent orchestrates the
activity here, and therefore
is a pretty critical player.
So again, these
chapters here are
pretty important for your paper,
and that five-step process
and understanding the
dynamics of innovation
are pieces that you're
going to need in your paper.
So Rasheed, it's all yours.
RASHEED: Great.
That's actually a
great place to start,
because I think a lot of
us were pretty much in line
with what was going on,
understanding what a legacy
sector is and identifying them.
We're pretty much
all OK with that.
Where I think people
started to diverge
was deciding on who would
play the role of these change
agents.
A lot of people were
looking in their questions
to figure out who would
be the best poised
in certain situations to play
that role of a change agent.
Would it change for
different initiatives?
And I think one of
the interesting things
was, we tried to identify of
this community of change agents
first.
We were all looking for
this thinking community
for different individuals.
So just to start
off with, who do you
think might be able to play a
role, in any particular case,
to be the change agent
for a legacy sector?
And it can be anyone.
AUDIENCE: I'll start it off.
This is a complex question.
There's different answers.
But I think for energy, I think
the big thing would be having
a breakthrough innovation.
Because the main
issue right now is,
we are worried about climate
change, but solar and--
well, solar in general is
expensive, and doesn't really
do what we need to do, because
if you look at the energy
market, how much is solar, it's
rather small versus our energy
needs and also the cost.
It's hard to innovate there.
But if you can come
up with a much,
much better innovation--
so maybe fusion.
Maybe there's something there.
It'd be the difference
between if you
had to come up with a whole new
phone line system versus if you
create the cell phone.
You might have a huge
opportunity there.
And the thing that I think
is important this issue is--
Steve Case, the
guy who made AOL,
has this thin called the
third-wave entrepreneur,
where it's like--
the thing about
innovating in this sector
is that, you kind of
Uberize it in terms of,
there's already an
existing society.
There's already all these
institutions that people--
there's these pathways
for this legacy sector.
So when you innovate
in it, the issue
is going to be that
you tear those down.
And these people will
spend their lives
dedicating themselves to
being part of the sector,
and you just cannibalized it.
So it's like, how do
you really work with it?
And that's a policy issue, but
it's also a whole social issue.
And I think Uber has been a
good preliminary basic example,
because--
it's pretty much an appetizer,
or a warm-up example.
But if somebody did come up
with an amazing innovation
in energy, like fusion
that is relatively cheap
and won't take like 10
years to build a reactor,
then maybe something
like that could happen.
Any other thoughts?
AUDIENCE: Maybe another good
example, probably almost
more disruptive.
You mentioned gasoline.
It would be-- that's part of
what makes Elon Musk a really
interesting change agent.
He's not just
developing the electrics
that drive the car, but
the charging stations that
will go in the
house, and then even
connected to the solar
roofing that will charge those
stations.
I think you put a lot of thought
into, basically, the launch
pathway for that technology.
STEPH: That's a
really good point,
because I think often about the
energy value chain in the oil
and gas industry-- like
upstream, midstream,
downstream-- and the flow of
value within the industry,
and I feel like--
I hadn't thought of that,
that Elon is essentially
creating not only upstream
change, but also midstream
change and downstream change,
in that he's comprehensively
trying to transform the
industry and capture
all of the value for himself.
But I definitely
think that perhaps--
or I don't know, maybe
I'll pose this question.
do you feel like
change happens more--
or change is more
feasible on the midstream
or downstream sector?
Because I feel like upstream
is kind of that disruption.
It's trying to create fusion,
which can be challenging,
and it can be difficult
to have people adopt.
But then you get stuck at
the midstream or downstream.
Do you want to change
infrastructure,
or do you want to change
consumer patterns,
is my question.
RASHEED: Steph, quickly
define upstream,
midstream, downstream for me.
STEPH: Oh, yeah.
So upstream is just the
production aspects of it--
so the extraction of
natural gas and oil.
So the derrick systems.
Midstream is the
infrastructure that's
created in order to
transport that-- so, say,
the railways, the trailers,
the trucks, et cetera.
And then downstream is the
consumer aspects of it--
so the people buying it
in their car at scale.
RASHEED: So I think what's
interesting about this--
and maybe particularly
in energy,
but in other fields and
other legacy sectors--
creating these thinking
communities of change agents,
which is the first
step, is something
that you can't really--
is there a way to
organically do this?
Because I don't see
getting together
the heads of all
of the big energy
corporations together in a room.
They're not going to come up
with anything super radical.
And so there's no--
and it's way different from--
before you could just get
the Comptons, the Vannevar
Bush in the room,
and you're going
to get something crazy out.
But now, if you're looking
to innovate in a sector,
you can't really call upon
the greatest minds pulled here
and then get something out.
AUDIENCE: Can you give
me an example [INAUDIBLE]
just to [INAUDIBLE]?
AUDIENCE: Well, isn't MIT trying
to create a thinking group,
or a space where thinking groups
can occur, with The Engine?
Isn't that one of--
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
Yeah, or Mighty could be
and the Energy
Initiative could be
seen as a thinking community.
It's not simply MIT-based.
It brings in all kinds of people
from various sectors and places
to think through
these big challenges.
And the big reports
that MIT does
are the products of these
thinking communities
as they attempt to think
through a new technology area,
like solar or the
future of the grid.
STEPH: [INAUDIBLE]
did you interact
at all with the American
Petroleum Institute?
SARAH JANE MAXTED:
Well, not really.
It was there.
It was affiliated--
I don't even know how.
I think it was out
of Office of Science?
Or was it Fossil?
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Fossil.
SARAH JANE MAXTED: Fossil.
I think the Office of Fossil
Energy has the relationship.
But we didn't interact
with them at all.
STEPH: So I think an
interesting example for Rasheed
within the legacy
sector of oil and gas,
because I know API
does a lot of work
in ensuring that the
regulatory framework is there
for all of the oil companies.
And the heads of all
the oil companies
get together as a group,
or provide representatives
at meetings, and
then they go through
and talk about the potential
outcomes for the energy
industry, and then
think collaboratively
about what that industrial
framework might look like.
And obviously, there's a
lot of those industries that
are trying to create
disruptive innovations,
because that's the
only way they're
going to win in the
market in the long run.
SARAH JANE MAXTED:
Well, I think there--
so there are--
I think something
to think about.
Most applied programs
in government have--
what do you call
them, working sessions
where they hear industry--
what do they call them?
Oh my god.
Peer reviews?
Oh, not peer reviews.
I don't know what
they call them.
But it's basically
where you bring together
the community of practice
of all of the people
that make sense
to bring together,
in solar and
batteries or whatever,
and you have a conversation
to identify pain points.
And all of the ERE does this.
The Energy Efficiency
[INAUDIBLE]
office and I know most
other applied programs
do as well, to kind of do that.
But I actually think--
to your point about,
does it really make sense to
get all these execs in a room?
Are they really going to
move the ball forward?
Is actually a really
interesting question,
because I think we're starting
to see more of the exevs
in the room with the
midstream and the downstream,
and all of the--
to actually be
innovative, it can't just
be the CEOs of these companies.
It has to actually be
different layers as well.
And I think that goes to this--
they can do this kind of model.
I don't know if that
answered the question.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: So
I'm going to need to--
if we're going to
get out of here,
I'm going to need to
do a wrap-up of today.
And then I want to talk
about next week's class,
because seven of you
will be presenting,
and I just want to go
through the dynamics of--
that's going to be a
different kind of class,
so I just want to
talk about that.
But before we do that,
Rasheed, why don't you
lay out you know some closing
thoughts for us on this piece?
RASHEED: Yeah.
So I didn't get to
it, and I was hoping
to, actually, another question.
But another idea
that everybody had
was identifying policy
and policymakers
to give this impetus towards
making these changes,
and making these
changes more politically
favorable and apparent.
And it's difficult in
these legacy sectors
because, I think,
you're facing and you're
up against powerful
vested interests.
And I think it's just,
to Martin's point,
making the case for, maybe
I don't have fusion yet,
but it's making it socially
applicable or politically
palatable to say, if we invest
here and get this fusion,
we can make this change
that can be politically
favorable for everybody.
And so I think looking
at policy incentives,
you have to think
a little bit bigger
than just what is scientifically
or technologically possible.
But I think this
is a great piece,
and this is was a great piece
for us because it encourages us
to not only think about
innovation systems as being
differentiating-- you can do
different things but achieve
the same result--
but also, a lot of people have
to buy into and get on board
and be coordinated
in their actions
to achieve feasible
and long-term change,
because we have a
lot bigger problems
than we did 50 or 100 years ago.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
And a lot of them
are tied to these
legacy sectors.
Thank you.
So I'm going to do a quick
wrap-up of this class.
So our backdrop was Donald
Stokes and Pasteur's Quadrant,
and that led us into
Branscomb and Auerswald.
And their underlying-- the focus
of innovation policy, frankly,
for the last 25 years
has been on the problem
that they write about, this
valley of death problem.
And how do you get across it?
But one thing I want
to be clear about today
is, the valley of death is
only one piece of a larger
innovation system which
stretch a lot further than just
research and
development, and we've
got to think about the gaps
in that system overall.
But Branscomb and
Auerswald really
lead us into this
foundational problem.
And a valley of death is
essentially a linear view,
and they also point out that,
hey, the system is really not
linear.
It's more complex than that.
It's this Darwinian sea.
Ruttan describes for us
this parallel universe.
We have a set of civilian
basic research agencies,
and then we have a very
differently organized set
of defense R&D agencies
and mission agencies.
And they are very
different systems,
and one is, from an
organizational point
of view purposely disconnected.
The other is
purposely connected,
and they are different worlds.
We have gotten a lot out of
that defense innovation system.
We don't normally think
about it or talk about it,
but the results
are quite powerful.
Glenn Fong told us
about the models
that DoD uses when
it's actually going
to play a role in
civilian sectors,
and laid out the byproduct
model, the spin-off model,
the dual-use model, the
industrial base model.
So these are all models
the DoD uses in practice.
We looked at In-Q-Tel,
which in some ways
is the most extreme model
of governmental intervention
into the private sector,
because it will actually
play the role of being
a venture capital firm
and take ownership positions
in companies that it wants
to encourage innovation in.
We talked about the new model
innovation agency piece.
Essentially, the idea here is
that the system isn't static.
It isn't standing still from the
time Vannevar Bush created it.
It has been changing pretty
dynamically over time.
And these outside crises--
the competitiveness
challenge in the 1980s,
the Sputnik challenge of
the later part of the '50s,
the energy technology challenge,
now this advanced manufacturing
challenge-- these are
all external elements
that have been driving
change in the US system
and pushing its model to be
more of a connected model.
And then the final reading
was about innovation
in legacy sectors.
As we discussed just now, many
of our deep societal problems
are tied up in these
legacy sectors.
And these legacy
sectors need innovation,
and they resist it
inherently in their model.
And how do you think about
innovation organization that's
going to start to
bring new technology
advances, new
innovative advances
into these legacy
sectors that they
will be disruptive of
their business models?
How do we start to
think about that?
Because we're now
into that project,
and we need to much more
systematically organize
our innovation organization
approaches to cope with it.
So that takes us
through class 6.
Next week is going to be
a different kind of class,
because you guys are going
to own it much more than I'm
going to own it.
So seven of you
will be presenters.
I'm asking that-- and I've
got pretty detailed directions
in describing the class.
If you've got
questions, let me know.
But divvy up the innovation
organization groups
you want to present on.
And as we discussed
a few weeks ago,
I'd love to have
innovation groups that
were based on other than dead
white males in the group.
So if somebody can
find some, fine.
And talk to me about them.
I may be able to
help you on sources.
If you can't, that's fine, too.
And these are very interesting
groups, so it's going to be--
whichever one you pick, these
are very interesting stories.
I think we'll have
fun with them.
And the great group
model takes us--
we've been talking about
institutional innovation.
We talked a lot
about that today.
Innovation at the
institutional level.
But innovation
belongs to people,
and they organize
themselves in groups,
and we have to understand
the dynamics of those groups
as well.
So that's what the
object of the class is.
So I'm going to
ask the presenters
to do three or four slides
on your group, and tell us
what they accomplished,
what they did.
Tell us what-- the rules that
they followed from the Bennis
and Biederman
framework, which is
one of the several
foundational readings
that everybody should read.
What were the rules
that they followed?
And then what is
a new rule or two
that you see them doing
that's different in the Bennis
and Biederman rule?
What's different about
your particular group
that contributes to our thinking
about how great groups operate?